bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler du mwc le mobile world congress
où je vais me rendre dans quelques jours
à barcelone
[Musique]
alors le mobile world congress
je sais pas si vous connaissez c'est un
petit peu le grand rendez vous annuel de
la téléphonie mobile tous les grands
acteurs sont là tous peut-être pas apple
mais en tout cas tous les autres seront
là c'est là où sera dévoilée la veille
le samsung galaxy s 9 il y aura aussi le
nouveau produit de huawei est
probablement le p 20 et y aura plein de
nouveaux produits c'est vraiment là où
sont les deals commerciaux c'est un
salon professionnel c'est un petit peu
le poumons et le coeur la téléphonie
mobile donc barcelone tous les ans
reçoit le mobile world congress
et cette année j'y vais c'est justement
pour ça que cette vidéo parce que j'y
vais mais je vous emmène avec moi alors
bien évidemment je peux pas vous prendre
dans mes bagages j'aimerais bien mais
c'est pas possible
mais par contre je veux vraiment savoir
ce qui vous ferait plaisir ce que vous
voulez que j'aille voir quels sont les
thèmes qui sont les plus importants pour
vous ce que vous attendez ce que vous
souhaitez pas voir est vraiment quelles
sont les priorités
alors la priorité des priorités c'est à
mon sens bien évidemment le nouveau
produit de samsung le galaxy s 9 et s9
plus il va y avoir aussi le nouveau
produit de huawei comme je le disais
probablement le p 20 là où ça me sauve
nous promet un appareil photo réinventer
huawei nous promet la reconnaissance
photographique reconnaissance au sens de
l'intelligence artificielle
effectivement chez huawei on l'a vu au
niveau d'autres produits avec le keirin
970 la reconnaissance de scène et votre
smartphone est capable mon vote une
photo de reconnaître et d'améliorer les
paramètres
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle il
devrait continuer là dedans est allé
encore plus loin donc il ya une vraie
guerre au niveau de ses deux concurrents
du point de vue de la photographie
lequel sera le meilleur photophone c'est
aussi une question à se poser pour ce
mwc édition des 1000 18 mai y aura plein
d'autres choses alors je vais aller
essayer de fouine un petit peu du côté
des écrans pliables avoir un petit peu
ce qu'il y à voir du côté de chez les
nouveaux os il ya des infos là dessus
c'est complètement possible aller voir
du côté de chez samsung mais à mon avis
il est encore
beaucoup trop tôt essayer de sentir les
tendances chaussée prononcent sur un
autre événement d'événements privés en
parallèle qui s'appelle le peuple comme
à la guerre il ya plein de choses à voir
et ce mwc et je veux savoir ce que vous
voulez ce que vous vouliez voir donc
marquer moi tout ça en commentaires
dites moi ce que vous voulez dites moi
ce qui vous ferait plaisir dites moi
quels sont vos attentes
les produits d'origine noire parce que
effectivement là je parlais très gros je
parle de huawei je parle de samsung mais
il y en a d'autres qui sont beaucoup
moins gros et très intéressants dont
vous marquez tout ça il ya peut-être
aussi des marques que je ne connais pas
encore si vous avez des attentes
mettez moi tout ça merci beaucoup vous
allez voir on va bien se marrer maillard
plein de choses je pense qu'à barcelone
il devrait faire un meilleur un meilleur
temps il va faire plutôt bon donc ça ça
avec plutôt chouette
bien évidemment je prends pas vous
publiez tout d'un seul coup vous
publierez comme d'hab
une vidéo par jour donc rester connecté
abonnez vous allez boire un verre plein
plein plein de trucs chouettes il ya le
mwc il y aura d'autres choses après je
vous dit pas tout je gardais surprise je
dise un peu je fais le suspense donc
voila merci beaucoup merci à vous
n'hésitez pas aussi à marquer en
commentaire ce que vous voulez ce que
vous ferez plaisir
en règle générale je suis à bova plaisir
pour me faire plaisir mais aussi pour
vous faire plaisir
à très bientôt soyez sages attendue bien
vos commentaires et on continue la suite
de l'aventuré maintenant à barcelone ou
à w7
ciao
[Musique]